he was a massive figure in the world of
theoretical physics and
many people would have heard of him and
yet i think it would be fair to say that
his work led to the probably three nobel
prizes being awarded
not to him though not to him not to him
and he could have been involved in
certainly at least two of them i think
uh he could have if things that had
turned out differently he was actually
born in 1932
in india in madras to i think british
parents who were working over in india
he came back to scotland to be educated
at college in scotland and he spent his
undergraduate
and postgraduate time at edinburgh
university
and then i think he went over to caltech
for a period for a year
before securing a position at imperial
college
and back in the late 50s at imperial and
he stayed there
until till he died so i knew him through
the through his work on cosmology and
then that required a knowledge of
particle physics and that in turn
requires a detailed knowledge of quantum
field theory tom was a pioneer of that
field the work that he developed the
techniques he developed have
applications not only in particle
physics cosmology but also in condensed
metaphysics and so he was able to
develop an area of physics which is sort
of the interface between condensed
matter and cosmology as well as his
pioneering work involving the higgs
particle
early universe face transitions symmetry
breaking gravity there was one thing i
discovered he worked in 1961 he wrote a
paper in which he looked at a
modification of general relativity i
thought recently that i've been seeing
references to this paper of tom's 1961
and i just look back in 19 2015 it had
over 100 citations this paper he wrote
you know that's the kind of impact he
had across the fields he was able to
write things and then it laid dormant
for a while and then people realized wow
this is real really impressive stuff
the first and the one that
60 symbols viewers will know
most about is probably the higgs right
the discovery of the higgs back in
2012 i think which led to the nobel
prize in 2013
the mechanism which is known as the
higgs mechanism was developed
independently by three groups one of
those groups involved tom he wrote a
paper that was published in physical
review letters and that has become one
of the flagship papers that they often
cite as being one of their key
contributions to the journal and he
wrote it with his friends garelnick and
hagen and because of this crazy law
rule that we've discussed that the only
the nobel prize can only go to three
people they decided i guess they
couldn't just give it to tom and not
give it to the other two they were
giving it to higgs and anglair quite
rightly
so tom missed out tom wrote a second
probably even more influential paper he
actually was the person that
demonstrated how you can use this
mechanism in the proper world of
particle physics and in that we knew
that one of the key particles
in nature is the w and z vector boson
these tell us about how the weak
interactions behave these are very
massive particles we didn't know how to
give these masses and tom is the person
that actually demonstrated how you do
this he came up with the actual
mathematical formalism to introduce
masses to these particles this then in
1967 he wrote this paper so three years
after the higgs mechanism he applied it
to this realistic situation provided the
breakthrough that helped weinberg
understand the standard model of
particle physics
and salaam so weinberg and salam shared
the nobel prize with glacial for this
standard model of particle physics it
also had a knock-on effect that the
formalism that tommy developed in this
1967 paper the very mathematical
formalism helped to hooft and
development understand that this model
standard model was what they call
renormalizable this means that you can
make actual predictions with the model
basically but the the formalism that
that tom had developed helped them they
then got the nobel prize as well and of
course you also have the fact that tom
independently and discovered the higgs
mechanism in 1964 which got the nobel
prize for higgs and angler so three
nobel prizes came out of work directly
related to tom i found it kind of the
most humbling experience i think i've
seen that day when
when the nobel prize was announced first
of all there's a delay you might recall
there was a delay of over an hour when
it turned out the delay was that we're
trying to find higgs
but
to let him know but people were thinking
well maybe they've told tom and thomas
turned it down because he would have
known that if he got it his two
collaborators wouldn't have got it that
wasn't the case but i have read
since
tom told his son robert that
he was actually quite relieved not to
have got the prize because if he had got
the prize it would have been at the
expense of his close friends and
collaborators of the of the original
paper well that's that's what tom
thought so i guess you have to go with
his wishes but what do you think about
the fact he never got a nobel prize i
mean he did win a lot of prizes he did
win a lot of prizes he's he is
recognized as being a you know
a giant in this field i think it's sad
that they didn't get it but i fully
appreciate his uh his attitude and his i
believe it you know
the day of the when the prizes were
announced he was being interviewed all
over the place and you didn't hear a
single word of bitterness or criticism
the closest i got where it was he said
well if they have these archaic rules
for the award of the nobel prize he
can't get it but he ne i knew him quite
well he was a good friend and
collaborator and he never ever
complained or said anything
and derogatory about
the award of the prize never what do you
think he was bringing to the table that
made him so exceptional what was his
sort of unique selling point or his
skill oh good question what was tom's
thing
oh okay so i was i was actually thinking
about this today finally enough coming
in
i think a mathematically incredibly
strong he knew
detailed mathematics about areas known
as group theory and homotopy theory
these played essential roles in for
example his understanding of group
theories and non-abelian gauge theories
allowed him to understand how this
vector boson could acquire a mass for
the w whilst the the photon remained
massless it was tom that realized this
and so he brought this
very detailed mathematical knowledge of
quantum mechanics quantum field theory
group theory homophobia theory to the
table coupled with
this
deep understanding of the physical side
he would when i worked with him he would
always be asking about the physical
consequences of a calculation you know
does it make sense physically we're
dealing with objects that are meant to
be in the universe does it make sense
can we already rule it out and and so he
was a physicist
but with a very strong mathematical bent
and that i think was this
unique thing that other people have it
but he had it in this particular
combination which was just right he was
kind he was gentle
he was never afraid to tell you if you
thought you were wrong
he was
determined to get things as accurately
as possible the number you know i worked
with him on quite a few papers i was
privileged to do that and the number of
iterations of papers where we would be
discussing words he would be the level
of words are we saying this right and
the calculations we would check double
check
he he was really rigorous in his
approach
but he had time for everyone there are
so many stories of tom
being
sort of
people
banging on his door when he was head of
department to imperial and coming in
almost off the street some people to
tell him their ideas and he would listen
and he would listen to them and then he
would he'd probably say i don't know
rather than dismiss things but he would
always listen he always had time young
scientists like when i arrived imperial
as a 24 year old 25 year old he had so
much time for people and to listen and
offer them advice that there is a little
story that might be worth
telling you about i i got invited to
give a seminar imperial they were
considering a hiring me for a postdoc
i was at newcastle doing a phd and it
wasn't in the area tom worked
so i worked really hard on my
presentation it was the time of
transparencies i
i made it way too technical as as new
people new fresh phd students do because
i was trying to impress so i went down
and gave this talk and it blew everyone
away because it was just too technical
apart from the few experts who already
knew it
so it wasn't great and then after the
talk uh tom went off he didn't ask any
questions he went off to his room
because he was head of department
and my friend ray rivers said well you
should go meet tom you know he's a
famous guy and you might be you might be
here as a postdoc so i went to his
office and sat down in his office and he
was at his table and he smiled
and he didn't say anything
nothing
and i'm thinking okay and a few what
felt like minutes went by and eventually
i said well it's me who's come to see
him i should say something so i said
well professor kibble i know
you're a very important person i really
respect your work and would like to
know what did you think have you got any
advice for me i'm just starting
and he looked and he went
don't write in yellow
so all my transparencies all my
equations i'd written in yellow none of
them had projected onto the board so
every single equation nobody could see
no so not only was it a really technical
talk nobody could see an equation
and then that was his bit of advice and
then we then we chatted a bit more and
in fact we
began a collaboration a couple of years
later when i returned
to the uk and uh well we had a fantastic
time but he was just he rather than
saying your talk was just rubbish you
just don't write in yellow
that was did you ever bring that up with
him like years later
do you remember saying that
he just smiled as he would he
you know he he would
tom you wasn't afraid of silence he
didn't feel the need he would never try
and dominate he hated being the center
of attention he just didn't want it
but he would always be prepared to tell
you you know give his thoughts on
something if you wanted to know but so
you could go for tea with tom and not
say anything it'd be fine and initially
it's a bit felt a bit awkward but then
you realize that no it's fine and then
you just say something and he'd reply
and
it was all it was all great
you can't how do you then give it to
three more
once i realized he hadn't got it i just
texted him and said i'm very sorry to
hear you didn't get it i think you
deserved it
and he replied
he replied almost immediately
and he just said thanks very much
you're such a bloody sky you didn't say
i know that was faithful